the scenes out of afghanistan have been
heartbreaking desperate people doing
whatever they can to flee the country as
the taliban re-establishes control over
the capital city and the rest of the
country
some people are calling it a catastrophe
other people are calling it a nightmare
and msnbc reporters are calling it
a relatively peaceful takeover
the country is essentially now in the
hands of the taliban for all intents and
purposes uh they've taken over kabul the
president or should i now say the former
president of afghanistan ashraf ghani
has fled the country the taliban have
taken over the presidential palace
they've renamed the country the islamic
emirate taken down the afghan flag and
hoisted up
their own colors and it's been a
relatively um peaceful if you like a
process they haven't had to fire a lot
of shots there hasn't been a lot of
bloodshed in kabul it was a pretty
straightforward takeover for them uh
they've also taken over the airport uh
they've been reports of shots fired at
the airport and taliban fighters are are
all over the place
but they're not in any sort of clashes
with us personnel although commercial
flights have so far been suspended
that's a lot of whiplash it's it's a
mostly peaceful takeover of the country
and it's peaceful and there are
definitely shots being fired by the
militants who are everywhere but it's
mostly peaceful turns out that
relatively peaceful takeovers much like
mostly peaceful protests seem to involve
a fair bit of violence but joe biden has
doubled down on the strategy in his
first comments since everything that he
said wouldn't happen happened in
afghanistan
with the president this week is it any
wonder that democrats want to ban donald
trump from ever appearing on a ballot
again i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from there's a verse
for that who says
all the afghan terrorists are going free
meanwhile domestic terrorists who took
pictures in the capital are rotting away
in solitary confinement good job o'biden
yes this is what the liberal order wants
they they want to go easy on terrorists
who want to destroy america and they
want to
define you to define half the country as
terrorists lock you up and throw away
the key at least that is the way
our political order works it's enough to
probably disturb your sleep at night
well if you want to sleep easy i
recommend you check out helix helix
sleep has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for somebody else
doesn't make any sense with helix you're
getting a mattress that you know will be
perfect for the way that you sleep they
got soft they got medium they got firm
mattresses they've got mattresses that
are great for cooling you down if you
sleep hot they even have a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers and the
mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again
you don't need to take my word for it
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq and
wired magazine
just go to helixsleep.com knowles take
their two minutes sleep quiz they will
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life
they've got a 10-year warranty you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
won't matter
because you're not going to want to send
it back
if you did they would pick it up for you
even if you don't love it but you're
going to love it helix is offering up to
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at helix sleep
dot com slash knowles that's helix
sleep.com knowles for up to 200 off and
two free pillows msnbc
sees the glass half full so that's the
same network by the way that called the
george floyd riots mostly peaceful
protests with the the buildings burning
down behind them now they're saying this
is a relatively peaceful takeover i
suppose as far as takeovers go it
actually is
relatively peaceful meaning yeah they're
executing lots of people and beheading
lots of people but there's no major
battle taking place in kabul because the
afghan military didn't even fight back
and the american forces were were
leaving the political leadership said
pull out of the country the state
department taking a similarly optimistic
view so the the state department
spokesman ned
price
is is confident
in the ability of the united states to
impel the taliban
to have an inclusive government
additionally the u.n security council
issued a joint press statement earlier
today calling for a new government that
is united
inclusive
and representative including with the
full and
full and meaningful participation of
women
the council spoke with one voice to
underscore that afghanistan must abide
by its international obligations
including to international humanitarian
law and ensure the safety and security
of all afghans and international
citizens
i'm sure that'll do it uh it's done it's
over i don't know why we spent 20 years
in a military occupation of afghanistan
when ned price could have just gotten on
tv
or and frankly he might still do this
written a strongly worded letter
to the taliban and said hey dear taliban
to whom it may concern at the taliban
you we want you to elect women to your
government and if you don't well we're
we in the international community will
be
very disappointed in you taliban okay so
maybe think about that
uh taliban as far as i can tell
completely ignoring the the demands of
the united states state department
uh one cnn reporter observing on the
ground a cnn reporter who is now wearing
a hijab because otherwise she'll be
killed she's now wearing hijab but she's
looking on the bright side she's saying
sure you know these guys seem pretty
they're saying mean things they don't
sound like they're going along with this
but
they seem friendly enough
they're just chanting death to america
but they seem friendly at the same time
it's utterly bizarre
they're look they're mostly friendly
terrorists who want to destroy our
country mostly friendly though and
actually i hate to give credit to cnn
too but
in a way they do seem kind of friendly
in a way that's the scariest part
because if you look at the clip their
children say oh that's to america
we took over the country
hey buddy buddy habibi that's to america
oh gosh
it's bad it's bad it's not looking good
seems like a contradiction but there it
is chanting death to america
but but mostly friendly
a takeover of a country but mostly
peaceful if you like contradictions by
the way you'll love joe biden's speech
joe biden
spoke yesterday he finally left camp
david he was ignoring the takeover
afghanistan for several days the
takeover afghanistan happened in exactly
the way that he and his administration
said it would not happen and so he
finally addressed it
it was a very very interesting speech it
tells you a lot about joe biden in the
state of the crumbling american empire
the highlights
it did not begin in the strongest
way
my national security team and i have
been closely monitoring the situation on
the ground in afghanistan
and moving quickly to execute the plans
we had put in place
to respond to every constituency
including and contingency including the
rapid collapse we're seeing now so
that's
i think within the first 10 seconds of
the speech of his slurred speech he
confuses constituency with contingency
they're very
very different things obviously
and the ruling class in this country
doesn't seem to have much of either
but actual constituency that supports
them or contingency plans because
everything went wrong in afghanistan
the speech did get a little bit better
from there he made a point that i think
is pretty popular he said
we
now as the official policy of the united
states
will not
nation build in every despotic country
around the world
our mission in afghanistan was never
supposed to have been nation-building
it was never supposed to be
creating a unified centralized democracy
our only vital national interest in
afghanistan remains today what has
always been
preventing a terrorist attack on
america's homeland i will not repeat the
mistakes we've made in the past
mistake of staying and fighting
indefinitely
in a conflict that is not in the
national interest of the united states
so this is a direct
contradiction of the bush foreign policy
the the george w bush foreign policy is
here we played it yesterday on the show
he articulated it in the second
inaugural address he said
it is now in america's vital national
interest to turn every country in the
world into an america-style democracy it
is it's not just our ideal
even that is a little bit wilsonian to
say that every other country in the
world has to look exactly like we do and
we're going to invade you if you don't
but he went even further he said the
justification which was never really
plausible
is that any country that is not a
madisonian democracy
poses an existential threat to the
united states it's in our urgent
national security interest to topple
every
government that does not resemble ours
in the entire world
it was
a wild climate as war wilson more
wilsonian than wilson it was it was more
progressive than the wildest
progressives but that came to define
america's foreign policy and certainly
the republican parties for for years
joe biden along with donald trump saying
that is no longer our policy along with
george w bush the first time he ran for
president by the way who said we're not
going to nation build
this is a reversal of that policy okay
and then
you know you know what biden had to
there was no way he was going to give
this speech without doing it
he was not going to take responsibility
for his disastrous exit he was not going
to take responsibility for bungling the
actual execution of this plan he was
going to
blame the bad orange man when i came
into office i inherited a deal that
president trump negotiated with the
taliban
under his agreement
u.s forces would be out of afghanistan
by may 1
2021
just a little over three months after i
took office
u.s forces had already
drawn down during the trump
administration from roughly 15
500 american forces
to 2500 troops in country
and the taliban was at its strongest
militarily since 2001.
the choice i had to make
as your president
was either to follow through on that
agreement
or be prepared to go back to fighting
the taliban
in the middle
of the spring fighting season this is so
pathetic it just looks so weak for the
president of the united states to come
out and say it was not my fault it's
everyone else's fault he also went on to
blame the afghan army so it's trump's
fault it's the afghan army's fault it's
not my fault please don't blame me it's
just weak already our country looks
extremely weak because we bungled the
withdrawal and now the president of the
united states can't even man up and take
responsibility so it was it was pathetic
and it was a rough start to his speech
but then incredibly he then went on to
contradict everything he said and he
doubled down on his decision and said he
was proud of it now if you want to make
the right decision i would strongly
recommend
you check out rockauto.com i'm going to
give you two different visions of your
saturday afternoon here's the one you
need a part for your car truck so you go
to the brick and mortar auto parts store
and you show up and then you wait for a
little bit and you're waiting in line
and then a guy
starts asking you questions what make is
your car what model what year what color
what this with that you don't really
know all the answers but finally figure
it out he goes in the back of the store
they don't have the part there's just
too many parts they can't stock all of
them so then he goes online he probably
goes to rockauto.com by the way orders
the part he says okay it's going to take
a week and then come back in a week and
he's going to charge you twice as much
or
you just go to rockauto.com they've got
all the parts available for your car
truck they've got reliably low prices
they do not charge
higher prices for the do-it-yourselfers
versus the pros it's the same price for
everybody and they're a family business
that's been serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years what are you going
to do what do you think makes more sense
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car truck write
knowles canada wlas and there how did
you hear about xbox so they know that we
sent you rockauto.com
joe biden opens up his first remarks on
afghanistan
by blaming everyone but him and slurring
his speech and mispronouncing words it
was really weak stuff but then at some
point
i guess as his speechwriter was writing
the speech he realized man this is bad
stuff okay i've i'm gonna have to
completely change course make a 180
degree pivot and say
did i stand by this decision and it was
the right decision
and joe biden actually starts to make a
little bit more sense when he does that
i stand squarely behind my decision
after 20 years
i've learned the hard way
that there was never a good time to
withdraw
u.s forces
that's why we're still there
here is absolutely right this is the
point that all the people who say that
we should have stayed in afghanistan who
are many people in the kind of liberal
establishment and some people in the
neo-conservative establishment they're
all sort of the same same blob but the
people who stay we should have stayed in
afghanistan
beyond this withdrawal and that it was a
mistake to pull out
the only logical conclusion of that is
that we should stay in afghanistan
forever that's it i spoke to my friend
charles kessler yesterday who was giving
his expert analysis of afghanistan and
he pointed out that to democratize
afghanistan as was george w bush's
mission
would take about 800 years probably
it took 700 years from the magna carta
in england to a full inclusive democracy
the sort of thing that the state
department's talking about took 700
years for the english
i'm going to say the english were a
little better suited for it and their
political institutions were better
suited for it
wasn't imposed by an invading force but
let's say
seven eight hundred years for for the
afghans
are we gonna stay in afghanistan for 800
years maybe some people think we should
maybe some people believe that we should
just hold afghanistan as an imperial
tortillary territory rather forever
okay
notice though how the people who think
we should have stayed in afghanistan
they never admit that they never admit
that that's what they're really saying
because they know the american people
don't want because 70 of the americans
wanted to get out of afghanistan because
we don't want to have an overseas empire
because we still view ourselves as a
republic and a nation-state that doesn't
just govern the entire world okay and
maybe that's right maybe that's wrong
and maybe we have to be a world empire
but that's the way the situation stands
and so joe biden's saying you know five
more years ten more years wouldn't have
made
a difference
but if afghanistan is unable to mount
any real resistance to the taliban now
there is no chance
that one year
one more year five more years or 20 more
years
the u.s military boots on the ground
would have made any difference
that part is absolutely right that part
is absolutely right i hate to say that
joe biden got it you know like a stop
clock twice a day he got that part right
and i think a lot of conservatives
understand that too
five more years wasn't going to do
anything 20 more years wasn't going to
do anything 800 more years might have
done something do we want to do that we
want to be we want to run afghanistan
for 800 years we want to be there not
not like we're in germany not like we're
in
south korea even
those those pl if we withdrew those
places wouldn't completely collapse
even before we got there those places
did have some kind of a political
tradition afghanistan does not
afghanistan is a group of warring tribes
that have been killing each other and
repelling invaders for a very very long
time
with no political tradition of
democracy or whatever else you want to
install there
wouldn't it it basically always kind of
would have looked like this i mean biden
bungled it there's no question about
that
but
the just a few more years brigade i
think is not being totally honest here
then biden goes back to his ridiculous
mealy-mouthed excuse-making he you know
there were a lot of excuses in this
speech but i think his excuse for the
scenes that are going on right now of
people falling off of airplanes
scrambling of helicopters lifting people
out of the embassy of all these sorts of
things that one took the cake
we're taking over air traffic control
we have safely shut down our embassy
and transferred our diplomats
our diplomatic presence
is now consolidated at the airport as
well
our diplomatic presence is now
consolidated at the airport that is a
really clever way of saying that the
taliban ran you out of your embassy
chased you down to the airport with
thousands of afghans and they were
clinging to your planes as they were
taking off
and that and then of course afterward
after he gave this speech which was
pathetic it didn't it didn't satisfy
anybody i felt frankly it was just about
the best he could do
after he gave the speech
he didn't take a single question
i know my decision will be criticized
but i would rather take all that
criticism
and pass this decision on to another
president of the united states yet
another one a fifth one
because it's the right one it's the
right decision for our people
the right one for our brave service
members who risked their lives serving
our nation
and it's the right one for america
thank you
may god protect our troops our diplomats
and all brave americans serving in
harm's way
see thank you
i'm brave i'm strong i'm making the
right decision
and i'm not going to take a single
question bye and then he went right back
to camp david he went right back to
vacation
even still
did you notice the trick of this whole
speech
you notice the trick of this whole
speech is
joe biden didn't answer the question
the question
that prompted this speech was why did
the administration bungle the withdrawal
from afghanistan why did this go
basically as poorly as it possibly could
have not even by our own standards but
by the biden administration's standards
the biden administration said the
taliban wasn't going to come take over
right away the biden administration said
it wasn't going to happen from a friday
to a monday the biden administration
said we're not going to see helicopters
like saigon that's exactly what we saw
but he wouldn't answer he didn't even
address that question
because joe biden
is a good politician
he is he you i i don't think he's
intelligent i don't think he's
particularly moral i don't think he's
competent when it comes to actual
statecraft but when it comes to being a
politician
the guy is a genius i know i know that
some republicans push back at me on this
but the guy has lasted in national
politics for 50 years even being a
bumbling buffoon the guy managed to get
himself picked to be vice president the
guy managed to become president of the
united states he didn't even campaign
the guy didn't even campaign last year
he became president
and what he is
pursuing here is the number one rule of
political communications which is
don't answer the question you are asked
answer the question that you want to
answer
you see this good politicians do this on
tv all the time
good journalists call them out for it
but good good politicians do this in
their speeches and so instead of saying
hey here's the explanation of why we
bungled this withdrawal he said hey i
think we should pull out of afghanistan
yeah duh 70 of americans agree with you
on that there's nothing courageous about
about offering that point of view
we've we've already settled that
question the question is why did it not
work then it goes right back to vacation
and now you know the next question you
know the next question is
how many refugees can we take in
okay we went in we bungled afghanistan
we accomplished virtually nothing in 20
years because of failed political
leadership and now we're going to take
in tens of thousands maybe hundreds of
thousands of afghan refugees these are
people who are not being vetted from one
of the most terrorist laden countries on
planet earth we're just going to take
them in that's a good idea right
ann coulter made this point
and other people have said it over the
years she said the strategy is invade
the world invite the world
well that's what we're doing we invade
the world we disrupt things like in
libya like in syria and then we bring
all of those
refugees we bring all of these foreign
nationals to america
is that a good idea i don't know doesn't
seem like the wisest idea actually even
many more liberal left-wing countries in
europe
are pushing back they're saying
absolutely not
now you
absolutely should not miss your chance
to win a trip for two you and a guest to
the daily wire studios to see candace
live this deal is going away after
wednesday
so you gotta act fast dailywire.com
subscribe head on over there get 25 off
with code vip also if you haven't heard
of reader's pass it's a great bargain
for this content just four dollars a
month the daily wire readers pass
unlocks exclusive editorial content that
unpacks trending political and cultural
topics penned by everyone from ben
shapiro to
yours truly to dan crenshaw to many
other people when you sign up with
readers pass you also get access to the
morning wire newsletter monday through
saturday email covering the top stories
you need to know available only to daily
wire members all of this can be yours
for just four bucks a month so act fast
because right now we're offering a one
month free trial get readers pass today
also since we got so much stuff to plug
if you're a fan of the matt walsh show
you've probably heard the sweet baby
gang well the sweet baby gang is in need
of a sweet baby anthem the daily wire is
opening up for submissions all
submissions should be in the form of
youtube video links will be judged
american idol style by matt and all of
us daily wire hosts but you the viewer
will be voting on which song wins to
enter go to dailywire.com
sbg submissions end on august 25th
voting will take place on labor day so
tune in to matt walsh's youtube channel
to watch the judging of the submissions
the winner will be announced september
8th on the matt walsh show to enter
dailywire.com sbg do we have any other
stuff to plug guys is that is that
enough okay we'll be right back with a
lot more
the united states is preparing to take
in tens of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of people from afghanistan
on the idea that you broke it you buy it
you know i frankly i don't think the
united states broke afghanistan actually
afghanistan today is exactly the same as
when we found it
although they they got a little slap on
the wrist for 20 years and we put the
taliban out of power for them
but it's not as though the country is in
worse shape today than before we invaded
we invaded in
20 years ago now in 2001 because the
taliban
had
allowed terrorist cells to to flourish
there
we kicked out the taliban government we
occupied the country militarily for 20
years with varying degrees of success
and then we left and now the taliban is
back
so i actually don't want to hear that
we've left the country worse off than we
found it we didn't leave it much better
off we left it exactly the same and the
argument is going to be now we've got to
take in endless numbers of afghan
citizens to come into the united states
this seems kind of crazy to me because
one if the afghans are not going to stay
and fight for their own country
then
should they at least go to countries in
the region we have a lot of allies in
the region why don't they go to nearby
countries and then plan their their
assault back on the oppressive regime in
their own country why don't they fight
for their countries what i'm saying
the argument you hear from the liberal
imperialists is well these people
these people they fought for us
they helped us and now we've got to
bring them to the united states as
though the afghans
have no interests of their own as though
they're helping the united states was
just pure charity it was charity to the
united states i appreciate their help
i'm i'm glad for the afghans who helped
the government of the united states to
accomplish some of its objectives
but this they're not they're not just a
charity case here
they made a strategic decision they
believed that it was in their interest
in their personal and national interest
to ally with the united states and they
did that and now the united states is
leaving after 20 long years and so
afghanistan does need to
form its own country afghanistan doesn't
need to defend itself at a certain point
and the people there need to stay and
fight for their country and if they're
not going to they should at least stay
in countries nearby
why don't they go to iraq another
country that we invaded why don't they
go to syria why don't i don't know why
don't they go to any of our allies in
the region
why don't they go to saudi arabia why
don't they go to israel why don't they
go to places around at least in the
general area of the levant so that they
can
go back into afghanistan when the time
is right and defend their country
you just don't see it
the united states is expected the united
states and europe are expected to take
in all of the world's refugees which is
why the movement of people into the
united states over the last 60 years is
the largest movement of human beings
ever in recorded history so some people
even in far left countries like france
are wising up to this
emanuel macron who is a liberal leader
sort of technocrat leader of france
he said
we've got to make sure
that
we don't we aren't expected to take in
all of the refugees
i'd play the clip but it's in silly
french you know and there's no there's
no reason to put that language on the
show
okay you get the ideas like blah blah
blah
but what he says
it's important what he says he says
the situation we're monitoring the
situation in afghanistan and
we need to make sure that we are
protecting against an influx of migrants
that are going to be coming we can't do
that we can't take in all the migrants
from everywhere else in the world
because then we're going to lose our own
country and our own civilization is the
implication he doesn't go quite that far
in his conclusion that's obviously the
implication here by the way it's not
just the afghans who want to come into
america
it's the americans who are stuck in
afghanistan right now there are quote
this according to reports thousands of
u.s citizens trapped in kabul with no
ability to get to the airport
the taliban right now is going door to
door looking for westerners
door to door this is a major crisis
we're stranding thousands of americans
there
we should not be considering
the ways in which we evacuate one single
afghan citizen before we get all of the
american citizens out of afghanistan not
saying we can't take in any afghans
on a limited basis
but surely the priority has to be the
americans not the afghans and i think
this confusion represents the the
broader confusion brought up by
afghanistan namely are we a nation that
has citizens where the government has a
special responsibility to the citizens
or are we a liberal empire that has no
special responsibility to americans that
actually is just promoting universal
values all over the world because we're
the world's where the world's only
superpower we're the only the world's
only power if these people are to be
believed and no distinction is to be
made between a citizen of afghanistan
and a citizen of the united states and a
citizen of mexico and a citizen of el
salvador it's all sort of the same
if anything if anything the liberal
imperialists treat
foreign nationals with greater care
than they do the citizens of the united
states
speaking of which i think this is why
one williams
liberal commentator
liberal commentator on fox news but he's
still a liberal commentator
it is now proposing in a column in the
hill
to prevent
donald trump
from ever running for president again
here's the column
let's agree former president trump is
running again
he's got a ton of money in his war chest
uh people are you know uh liberals are
trying to sue him for various things or
investigations but none of that is
likely to stop him from launching trump
24
but attorney general merrick garland
might be able to stop him garland has
the power to rule out another trump run
by citing section 3 of the 14th
amendment which bars anyone from holding
office who engaged in insurrection
against the united states
this this
therefore what williams is citing right
here is advice from a leftist robert
reich she was a former labor secretary
and so william says if garland takes
reich's advice
he is sure to set off alarms about the
attorney general playing politics but
garland has the facts on his side
so you just declare that trump staged an
insurrection and then you prevent him
from
from running again now
the issue of course is that trump did
not do this
at all i don't think there's any
argument no one's even really suggested
it until juan williams is you know hail
mary here to stop trump from running
again
think about what this means
for the election
we were told
that donald trump got trounced oh he
lost by more votes than any president
ever
joe biden got the most votes of any guy
who ever ran for president trump got
crushed
it wasn't even close
and that's why we need to rewrite the
constitution to prevent him from ever
appearing on a ballot again
you see the contradiction here
you see oh they're kind of undermining
their own art trump is so unpopular
that the american people elected this
vegetable who can't pronounce his own
name joe biden they they elected him by
the widest number of votes ever
and that's why we need to fundamentally
reorder our constitutional republic to
make sure that people never have the
chance to vote for trump again uh seems
to me
like they know that trump is actually
pretty popular seems to me that they
know that joe biden is actually not very
popular
seems to me that the people who are
proposing an insurrection a coup d'etat
an upending of our republic
are the people on the left
the left is not very popular right now
among the ruling class it's obviously
that it they're the same thing but
among the american people not very
popular
there's a new cbs poll over in
california
gavin newsom
democratic governor
in a
democratic state
as democratic estate as ever there was
where republicans are out registered
by huge huge margins
right now the campaign to recall
democrat governor gavin newsom
basically 50 50.
cbs news you gov poll released on sunday
shows 48 of likely california voters
want to recall newsom 52 oppose his
removal
and here's the kicker the margin of
error is four percent
so this is statistically a dead heat
that is shocking
in a place where democrats outnumber
republicans what two to one or more
you've got the recall question for the
governor at 50 50.
and so the way that the recall election
works is the voters will have a choice
recall or don't recall if they vote to
recall him then the first guy they're
gonna then the second question is gonna
be who should replace him and there's
gonna be a list of a lot of candidates
but the guy who gets the most votes on
that list
will just be the governor
that's how it works
which means
that
libertarian
conservative radio host larry elder
could very possibly be the next governor
of california gavin newsom knows that
which is why he is now going after elder
by name
what
could happen on election day if we don't
turn out
in historic numbers to vote no on this
recall you have someone
that's not just opposed to one's right
to choose he is
but actually wrote an op-ed saying women
are not as smart as men
on issues of civic affairs and issues of
economics on issues of politics
he's someone that doesn't believe in
assault weapons ban
someone that doesn't believe in a
corporate tax should be zero doesn't
even believe in a minimum wage a fight
for 15 he doesn't believe there should
be a minimum wage be zero dollars
doesn't believe the time of historic
wildfires and droughts
the challenges we all face here in the
bay area the looming prospects of an
earthquake doesn't even believe in fema
thinks fema should be eliminated as he
does
the elimination of social security as we
know it wants to privatize he wants to
cut medicaid wants to cut medicare i go
down a list he's to the right of donald
trump
to the right of donald trump all right
this is preposterous
it's just not true
larry elder is not to the right of
donald trump i wish he were i really
like larry elder but he's a little
libertarian compared to the rest of us
he is still i think by far the best
candidate to replace newsome because
he's got the name recognition he's got
the ability to raise money he's got the
ability actually to do it and he's and
he's pretty good it would be such a vast
improvement over news it's not even
funny
but but the hyperbole is so preposterous
he's to the right of don he's a
libertarian
donald trump
who donald trump's politics are a little
complicated but he has i think a little
bit more of a conservative gut
larry elder certainly more of a
libertarian
got with this shows is not only that
gavin newsom is dishonest what this
shows
is that gavin newsom is
terrified of larry elder
terrified because
kevin faulconer might be a great
republican down there in san diego but
he's just not raising the money he
doesn't have the name recognition john
cox already ran against
gavin newsom
last time didn't didn't work out he got
trounced and the a lot of the other
republicans don't even know their names
and then the only other one whose name
we know is bruce jenner
who says he's he's not loyal to the
republican party he doesn't have
particularly conservative views actually
he says he's loyal to his community
meaning the lgbt community with an
emphasis on the t that's the that's the
most conservative candidate we can put
up a guy whose number one issue is
pretending that men can be women and
women can be men
a man who's obviously suffering from a
great deal of confusion about elemental
aspects of the world
so that was going to be a joke that was
the democrats best hope was that bruce
jenner becomes the number one candidate
and then
newsom you know just marches back into
the governor's mansion and then along
came larry elder
larry elder actually offered voters
a choice he might not be as far right as
as people wish that he were but
especially given that it's california
especially given this particular race
that's that's real i mean you can see
newsome sweating it was even in that
interview at the sacramento beery he
just lost his temper he goes this damn
state i'm not getting enough damn credit
people everyone here they're all
complaining about me they're jealous of
me they're jealous of my success
but they are uh
they're not they're not people are fed
up with that the the people i think the
american people and even the people of
california are fed up with the failed
leadership of the ruling class which has
hollowed out our country not just for
the tenure of gavin newsom but for
decades now
there's some great governors in this
country
even with the cuomos even with the
newsomes there's some great governors
including
my own governor bill lee here in
tennessee
governor bill lee just issued an
executive order on masks in schools
and governor lee presented it in this
way he said quote no one cares more
about the health and well-being of a
child than a parent i am signing an
executive order today that allows
parents to opt their children out of a
school mass mandate if either a school
board or health board enacts one over a
district
this is good stuff this is this is good
governing it's it's smart
the thing that's really smart here is
he's not going all the way and saying i
ban
school districts from even enacting a
mask mandate i sort of would prefer that
frankly because i want to send a very
clear message but this is politically
going to be a lot easier to implement
because what he's saying is okay school
boards yeah sure yeah you can institute
whatever mandates you want guys
but i'm signing an order that anyone
that wants to can opt out of it
and by doing that he's just completely
gutted their power
it's it's all it's almost more
humiliating because they can pass their
mandates but the mandates won't have any
teeth and this is absolutely right it is
child abuse to force little kids to
muscle themselves
for what now years on end we were told
it was 15 days now it's going to be
years on end
it's it's wrong
it's not good for them psychologically
it's not good for them spiritually it's
not good for them politically and dare i
say it
it's probably not all that great for
them
medically either to just have some
filthy cloth over your face all the time
just ask dr fatchi about that
great stuff out of tennessee now
some other people outside the governor's
mansion are not so
happy about the
republican rule in this state
you've got you've got the people
who want the good conservative
government and then you've got the
ruling class and the ruling class is
very often not even elected they're
usually just the bureaucrats the
thauchies of the world they're the
technic rats who are unaccountable to
the people who can just tell you what to
do and they think that you ought to just
follow them regardless of their whims
and their caprices so the top tennessee
public health official is very upset
that people are not
listening to her demands
and so she is now claiming that she was
sent a threatening package
she is the top vaccine official in
tennessee michelle fiskus she is
claiming that she was sent
a muzzle
this was one week before she was fired
from her position
that's pretty bad so then there was an
investigation into this taken up by the
tennessee department of safety and
homeland security and you know what i
found out
found out that
michelle fiskus sent the package to
herself
and this happens
so so
often
not just with claims
from public health people but with
people who are claiming racist attacks
people claiming sexist attacks
time and time and time again it turns
out to be a hoax perpetrated by the
people themselves jesse smolette this
woman the top tennessee health former
top tennessee health doctor
health official rather
is the the jesse smolette of tennessee
sending the package to herself it wasn't
even hard to find it out it was an
amazon account opened that she opened up
and it was purchased on a credit card in
her name
state said the case was closed on monday
victimhood carries a great deal of
currency
which brings me to lizzo
lizzo you know she's a sort of famously
husky singer you know that she makes her
large her corpulent appearance a big
part of her act she just released a new
song and now she's
upset and complaining about what she
called fat phobic
comments on the video it doesn't matter
how much
positive energy you put into the world
you're still gonna have people who have
something
something mean to say about you
i just feel like i'm seeing
negativity
directed towards me
is fat phobic
just racist and it's hurtful
you don't like my music cool
if you don't like rumors the song cool
but a lot of people don't like me
because of the way i look
okay so i'm gonna preface my comments
here by saying there's a very good
chance that this is just a publicity
stunt
it seems to me that anything that
entertainers do in the media
while they are promoting a new song or a
new book or a new movie or whatever
is
crafted by publicists and geared to get
publicity so it might just be the case
that lizzo is just pulling a publicity
stun here but let's take her at her word
then that is sad we feel bad about that
we don't want someone to be made fun of
for the way they look or being
overweight or something like that
now
lizzo uses this term fat phobias though
it's irrational to not want to be very
unhealthy and i think that that's the
problem that people are having here
if
i think the reason that people are
pushing back against this stuff at the
crazy sex stuff and and the crazy you
know saying that it's really good to be
extremely unhealthy or it's really good
to
whatever you know have any kind of uh
quality about you that
traditionally we would want to improve
but now we're saying no actually this is
much better this way to be unhealthy
it's that
we're
pretending that
there aren't
standards at all we're
actually that standards are inverted and
that that people push up against
that people are saying no actually it's
it's not good to be a man who like
mutilates yourself to look more like a
woman that's not good we don't want to
be mean to you we don't be cruel to you
but it's not good you should try not to
it's not good to be really unhealthy
for your own sake out of compassion we
should try to help you not do that you
know but
but what what has happened in our
culture where victimhood carries
currency is that actually
in a way it is politically and socially
advantageous
to have one of these things about you
you know the sort of oppression olympics
the idea if you're if you're a man who
thinks that he's a woman this is
actually really good for you it kind of
gives you a pass in society from certain
criticisms
but it is
assuming that liz's feelings really are
hurt people really are being mean to her
this does remind us of something i was
actually just reading plato
on the airplane on the way here a few
days ago and
socrates makes this point he says it is
worse
to
harm somebody than it is to be harmed
and this is a uniquely western concept
and it actually helps make sense of
what's going on in afghanistan and it's
going on
in the rest of the world it is worse to
harm somebody than to be harmed that is
a concept that comes from the deepest
western traditions it is developed fully
in christianity
and we'll just have to go into that
tomorrow there's a lot more to say on
this topic but we'll have to we'll have
to save that for two how's that for a
cliffhanger i'm michael knows this the
michael knowles show
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borin our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021. today on the
ben shapiro show president biden
triumphantly announces america's
surrender in afghanistan as the taliban
reimposed dystopian theocracy and
murderer erswell allies that's today on
the benchmark show give it a listen
you